So
let's get rid of the fixes.
I Ita,
so sometimes he listed it as a lack of,
as you apply critical thinking language.
It's almost like it's like a mathematical
problem and the logic association with
contribution of herbs,
I feel sometimes they're locking and this
is basic knowledge and kind of put two
and two together.
The best way,
the best way to teach people critical
thinking is to teach them to write.
And I,
I made this little
thing that I put online.
It's,
I don't know if maybe it is
it in the site for 34 website.
Did I post that rubric for Essay Writing?
I don't think it actually went through.
I think it is still on four 30
is it not on four 34 is that not working?
It's true.
When you were doing it.
Oh yeah,
I bet.
I still found it.
It's still in corporate before 30
Oh,
okay.
Well there's an essay.
Oh that's too bad.
It's not on the site for 34 website even
I didn't cause I updated it anyways.
I have this guide to writing.
It's that if it isn't
on the four 34 website,
it is definitely on the four 30 website.
And uh,
it steps people through the process of
writing because what's happened now,
it's very hard to teach people to
write because it's unbelievably time
intensive.
And like writing marketing a
good essay that's really easy.
Check a,
you did everything right,
right.
Marking a bad essay.
Oh my God,
the words are wrong.
The phrases are wrong,
the sentences are wrong.
They're not ordered
right in the paragraphs.
The paragraphs aren't coherent and
the whole thing makes no sense.
So trying to tell the
person what they did wrong,
it's like,
Whoa,
you did everything wrong.
Everything about this essay is wrong.
Well that's not helpful either.
You have to
find the few little things they did half
right and you have to teach them what
they did wrong.
It's really expensive.
And so what I did with this rubric was
try to address that from the production
side instead of the grading side.
But the best thing you can do is teach
people to write because there's no
difference between that and thinking.
And one of the things that just blows me
away about universities is that no one
ever tell students why they
should write something.
It's like,
well,
you have to do this assignment well
why are you writing while you need the
grade?
It's like,
no,
you need to learn to think because
thinking makes you act effectively in the
world.
Thinking makes you win the battles you
undertake and those could be battles for
good things.
If you can think and speak and right,
you are absolutely deadly.
Nothing can get in your way.
So that's why you learned to write.
It's like why don't,
I can't believe that people
aren't just told that it's,
it's,
it's like
it's the most powerful weapon you could
possibly provide someone with and I mean
I know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watch them
throughout my life.
I mean those people,
you don't want to have
an argument with them.
They'll just slash you into pieces
and not in a malevolent way.
It's like if you're going to make your
point in there and to make their point,
you better have your points organized
because otherwise you are going to look
like and be an absolute idiot.
You are not going to get anywhere.
And if you can formulate your arguments
coherently and make a presentation,
if you can speak to people,
if you can lay out a proposal,
God,
people give you money,
they give you opportunities,
you have influence.
That's what you were at university for.
And so that's what you do is you urinate
Irin English right here and yeah,
new languages anyways.
It's like,
yeah,
teach,
teach people to be articulate because
that's the most dangerous thing you can
possibly be.
So,
and that's motivating.
If people know that,
it's like,
well why are you learning to write?
Because your,
here's your sword,
here's your m 16 right?
Here's your bulletproof vest.
I like you're learning how to use them,
but
it's just,
it's an endless mystery to me
why that isn't made self evident.
So
that's the sort of thing that can
drive you mad trying to sort out.
It's like people are,
there's a,
there's a conspiracy to bring people
into the education system to make them
weaker.
So
I guess that keeps the competition down.
Maybe that's one way of thinking about it.
If your students are stupid,
they're not going to challenge you.
So other questions,
disagreements,
I mean it's a pretty harsh
indictment of the university system
when you were talking about marriage.
Um,
you get to play points
if you stay,
uh,
which is of course a really good point.
You,
you have more possibilities
to them towards a solution.
Yeah.
But that is also,
it's also assume that you
will always get a solution.
Yes,
true.
yes,
yes.
Hello.
What a solution that
will keep the marriage
true?
Well,
you know,
there used to be,
before the divorce laws
were really liberalized,
there wa there you could
sue for irreconcilable
differences and sometimes people
do find themselves in that situation.
It's like one person wants children and
the other person doesn't like that's a
tough one.
It's a tough one to negotiate.
So I'm,
I'm certainly not saying that just
because you lock yourself into a like two
cats in a barrel,
that that will make you
solve your problems because
problems are hard to solve
and sometimes you can't solve them.
I was just pointing out what the cost of,
of leaving the back door,
what the cost of leaving
the back door open is.
And it's a big cost and a,
you know,
one of the things I see too is that
people's identities fragment increasingly
across time.
You know,
one of the things that you have as you
age is something like the continuity of
your life.
You know,
you,
you have someone that you're with,
you've tied your story
together with theirs,
you have children,
maybe they have children.
It's like there's this continual pay off,
so to speak in quality that you
obtained from staying within that frame.
And you can jump out of that.
And I suppose to some degree
that that provides freedom,
but it isn't obvious to me
that it does that for sure.
People
once this relationship,
it's a my blood email.
No.
But,
but,
but it's also the case that sequential
relationships are unlikely to be that.
Okay.
So look,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not making,
I'm definitely not making a
utopian case for marriage.
I would like to hear the case where it
was from you because they make it really
interesting.
Right?
It says talk point,
but at the same time,
I think there are some
relationships that are waking Oh,
quality.
Yeah.
And if we,
if that's the case,
then insisting is on the,
uh,
cannot be good.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's definitely the
alternative argument.
And of course there are strong
things to be said on both sides,
but
see there's some,
there's some additional problems with
divorce that people don't really grasp
when they're young.
Like the idea that you can be
divorced once you have children,
that's kind of a stupid
idea because you can't,
you can,
you can find a limited substitute
for your initial freedom.
But if you,
if you have kids and
you try to get divorced,
the probability that that's going
to demolish your life is very,
very high.
First of all,
it's incredibly expensive.
So one or both of you is going
to come out of that poor and
your market value has declined.
Let's say you're the
woman who takes the kids.
Your market value has declined radically.
You're going to be poorer.
The man,
he's just a screwed because he is now
an indentured servant and there's no
escape from it.
So it's an,
it's not so bad if you can negotiate a
peaceful separation and some people can,
but lots of times if you
have a terrible relationship,
it's not like negotiating
a peaceful separation.
It's all that easy.
But if you're at each other's throats,
good luck to you.
I think it's roughly equivalent
to having nonfatal cancer.
It is not pleasant.
It's a 10 year process,
15 year process.
It'll cost you $250,000 and it'll tear
a big chunk out of your life and also it
will really disrupt your relationship
with your kids and you know,
you bring kids into a step parent family,
they do not do as well.
Step parents are not as good parents as
biological parents and the data on that
is clear.
Now,
obviously there are exceptions because
there are terrible biological parents and
there are wonderful step parents.
But if you look in aggregate,
it's not that easy to care for children.
You need to everything you
can binding you to them.
And if there's someone else's children,
mostly they get in the way
of the person that you love.
Right?
Well,
if I'm,
let's say you have a child,
I'll be right out.
Let's say you have a child
and I want to go out with you
every second you spend with
that child is a second.
You don't spend it with me and,
and there's gonna be a price for that.
I'm not going to be happy about that.
And,
and if I have a child,
you're going to feel exactly the same way.
You might say,
well,
no,
I love children.
It's like,
yeah,
sure,
sure you do.
I doubted you might love your child.
And,
and you know,
it's pretty specific the way
that people loved children.
So,
and the rate of abuse for kids in step
parent families is way higher than it is
in biological families.
There's not even any comparison.
So anyways.